يدرون الشاحنات والطائرات والسفن
باسنانهم واكتافهم وايديهم او يحملون
اوزان ضخمه من الحديد بواسطه اذانهم
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
وظيفه الاسنان هي الاكل ومضغ الطعام لكن
هناك من يوظفها لاستخدامات اخرى هنا الهند
حيث تقام مسابقه فريده للسكان لاستعراض
مهاراتهم وقدراتهم
هذا الرجل عليه ان يمرن عضلات فكه بدلا من
عضلات يده ليصبح قادرا على سحب دراجه
بخاريه بركابها الثلاثه مستخدما حبلا
باسنانه
اما هذا فيستخدم اذنه لرفع الاثقال نعم
كما سمعتم الهندي يرفع اثنين وتسعين كيلو
جراما من الحديد بواسطه اذنه
بكل اسمهم
[موسيقى]
هنا قدرات خارقه من نوع اخر لهذا الرجل
الذي يدعى صاحب سينج اذ يربط سلاسل حديد
صلبه حول جسده وقدميه ثم يكسر تلك السلاسل
بقوه وحرفيه امام الجماهير
هذه الاستعراضات الجسديه لا توجد في الهند
فقط في ايران مثلا يسحب هذا الرياضي
البالغ من العمر ثلاثه وثلاثين عاما شاحنه
تزن اكثر من ثلاثه عشره مستخدما عضلات
كتفه ورقبته فقط وفي روسيا سحب ايفان
سفينه تزن اكثر من عشره الاف طن لمسافه
مترين كاملين
استراليا
[موسيقى]
من الجلي ان اولئك الابطال الخارقين
يقدمون على تحديات
لاظهار قدره اجسادهم على التحمل وكسر
الارقام القياسيه المسجله او طمعا في
الشهره وتخليد اسمائهم لكن ورغم القوه
الظاهره على اجسادهم الى ان الطب يحذر من
هذا النوع من التحديات التي من الممكن ان
تؤدي الى اصابات خطيره وربما اعاقه دائمه
فهل تستحق الشهره ولا القاب كل تلك
المخاطره